what you see on the title slide is the
environment um where our manipulation
Pro uh problem takes place uh so we'll
be talking about this it's a little bit
of something for everyone uh one of my
favorite things about robotics is we
need Hardware software motion planning
control computer vision machine learning
you know manufacturing operations uh
we've got it all so here's a teaser at
the start um the task is to put
inventory onto these bookshelves and the
bookshelves are made of a really heavy
fabric kind of a canvas so it's a little
bit flexible we've got these mesh
elastic bands that sit in front of those
bookshelves protecting the items from
falling out um you can see there's a
diversity of items it's basically
anything you could buy on amazon.com
that's less than 20 PBS less than 24 in
um they get stored randomly so it's not
like it's all iPhones in one shelf uh it
could be a teddy bear next to an iPhone
next to a bowling ball next to a light
bulb so uh Mark mentioned this I did
have a whole lot of fun my first 15
years as a roboticist first first here
and then at JPL um I won't be won't be
talking about that today I did do a
robotics Institute uh seminar at
Carnegie melon in the fall of 2019 and
that's right when I was making the
transition and so I actually remembered
everything cool we were doing about ice
climbing and asteroid gripping and um if
you're really interested in that I
encourage you to look it up on
YouTube so this is an Amazon warehouse
um I want to talk you through the sort
of overall process and then we'll zoom
in on the manipulation problem that
we're trying to solve um trucks
basically show up and this is the
inventory arrives step we unload all of
those items that are not yet for sale um
we store them on those yellow
bookshelves we break them down singulate
them so it's a one by one process of
storing them randomly on those
bookshelves at that point they're for
sale uh on the website and when a
customer orders one of those items uh we
pick it off of that same bookshelf try
and accumulate it with any other things
that you've ordered within the last you
know 6 to 12 hours um pack those into
the small and greenest shipping
container that we can um uh get you your
order in and sometimes that's no
shipping container at all right I order
a lot of diapers these days it just
comes with a shipping label on the on
the diaper box um once those once those
packages are um sealed we do another
sortation step to make sure everything
coming to Stanford University is in one
truck and everything going to Meno Park
is in a different truck and then those
trucks you know uh go out uh into the
network uh one thing to talk about is
there's a big supply chain that exists
before this um with ports and boats and
factories and inbound cross stocks and
there's a big distribution Network that
happens after this building which is
delivery stations third-party carriers
like FedEx and UPS further sortation
centers um what you see here is just how
many of these bookshelves there are
60,000 of them in a given fulfillment
center there is 25 million items that
would sit on those
bookshelves uh we process on good days
over a million items uh in a single
day uh so it is a a large scale
problem with that scale comes both
opportunity and challenges so something
that's a one in a million occurrence is
a 10 or 20 times a day thing at Amazon
so these edge cases the reli ability um
your ability to handle those things
quickly and efficiently becomes really
important um on the opportunity side if
you want to retrain a new model we have
massive amounts of data right so we have
a package sorting robot called Robin um
that's now done something like two or
three billion picks and we have the
kinematics and the and the trajectories
for all two or three billion of those
picks and in fact we just published a
big data set um to make that available
to the community so that we could um try
and analyze and and leverage that data
um there's also because of this scale an
tremendous opportunity to have a big
impact right so uh if you can deliver
something you know it's going to go out
and it's going to change the business um
pretty
substantially so let's zoom in here on
Stow this is what I'll be talking about
this is what we call that step of
putting the items onto the bookshelf um
you see a Ka robot that's what these
guys here are that are moving those
bookshelves around
see if we can get that to play again
um it comes to a person so rather than a
person walking down long aisles you know
with a shopping cart these robots are
now bringing the bookshelves to the
people um they will scan an item uh and
then place it onto that shelf I think
I've got another video yeah and one of
the favorite inventions Amazon came up
with a few years ago for me is um she'll
scan the item itself so we get a you
know barcode read here but once she
places it into the bin there's no
subsequent scan there's a machine
learning model it's using a couple of
cameras that watches where the person's
hands goes into the bin and
automatically transfers that inventory
into the appropriate shelf um and that's
deployed widely at scale so it saves a
couple of seconds on each of these
stoves and it also makes it way more
ergonomically friendly you don't have to
carry a barcode scanner with you um when
you're doing this task other things you
might observe when you're watching this
um is the workspace so we need a ladder
to get up to the top shelves you got to
crouch down to get down to the bottom
shelves we really want these warehouses
to be as dense as possible um when
you're buying a 1 million square foot
building outside of Tokyo or New York
City or San Francisco uh the real estate
costs are quite expensive and so density
is really important to keeping keeping
the prices low for our customers um
you'll also notice she's doing some
decision- making here so she's uh in her
head figuring out which item will fit
which bin um and how to make space in
that bin and when to kick that shelf out
and get a new one in um that has more
opportunities so it's this kind of
matching game that you need to do uh and
then the manipulation tasks themselves
right so dealing with those elastic
bands is not trivial um making sure that
item will fit especially if it's kind of
a dense fit as we're getting ready for
the Christmas season the holiday season
these things are getting as full to the
gills as we can get them um and so
sometimes it's pretty forceful to get
stuff to fit in there and you've got to
think about whether you're going to
damage the item if it's a box of
batteries you can probably you know use
use a lot of strength and if it's a an
iPhone maybe you want to be a little
more
careful so if we think about this from a
robotics perspective it's kind of these
steps you perceive the the Shelf decide
what goes where you open those elastic
bands grasp the item you're going to
Stow do this pre-manipulation inside the
bin to get the space you need to Stow
that item and then place the item onto
the shelf so we'll get pictures of um
the state of those shelves but we also
have metadata on all the other items
that are already on that shelf including
properties like their you know
Dimensions the weight um we track things
like whether they're compressable or not
whether they're bagged or not whether
they're fragile liquid you know lithium
batteries that kind of
stuff we need to open those elastic
bands um so here you see a two jaw
version grasp the item uh in this case
one of the simplifications we were able
to do is is feed the item into the hand
using a conveyor um so there's not a lot
of grass planting that was something we
were able to get away with uh we make
space in the bin using a pretty simple
manipulator it's a piece of sheet metal
uh that can extend in and out uh and
then we Stow the item and here these are
actually conveyor belts that are part of
our gripper and so we don't have to put
the entire gripper into the bin which
takes up a lot of space we can kind of
feed that item in the things we care
about uh is how fast can you go um we're
talking about hundreds of units per hour
so you're you know 10ish seconds is a
good rule of thumb to do this entire
task uh eligibility this is um material
to be handled so what kind of items can
you deal with um I like to call us a
partial credit solution so if there's a
really particularly tricky you know dog
toy or uh something like that we don't
need to Stow 100% of the inventory uh we
put some thresholds and we keep an
exclusion list so there are still people
that are doing some of those hard items
and this is one of those let robots do
what robots are good at let people do um
those High dexterity tasks that are
maybe still uh a bit in front of the
state-of-the-art for robotics today so
our eligibility at the moment is you
know 70 80% of the items um and that's
actually very good um fullness so how
how much stuff can you fit GCU is gross
cubic utilization so it's sort of
volumetric fullness um damage we want to
minimize the number of times we poke a
hole in something or drop something uh
amnesty is our word for you know the
item is is left the bin um either at
your station you've dropped it on the
floor or you didn't get it into the bin
and so when that ke robot takes it away
somewhere as it's driving around it
falls out um we call that
amnesty so this is our sort of marketing
version of the video um I'll show you
more but what you can see from this one
is that we have a robot arm that rides
on a seventh and eighth axis we have a
horizontal vertical Gantry that's to
grossly position the arm either at the
top row bottom row middle row um then we
have a second robot that sits in front
of that system that's doing the elastic
band manipulation and that's a Gantry
robot um we have three degree of freedom
and four degree of Freedom versions of
that you also see our end of arm tool
there which enables the item to be you
know conveyed into the grasp and then
ejected into the bin um without putting
that gripper in the bin manipulator it's
just an extendable piece of sheet
metal so a choice me we made early on
was to break the process into two steps
so we singulate the items first um and
then we Stow them and that enables that
conveyor feed into the gripper we're not
trying to pick the items out of a tote
that might have you know 10 or 20 items
in it um that's the singulation step and
this is kind of a philosophy lesson I
guess I'll get on the soap box for a
moment um trying to create a generalized
you know can do everything kind of uh
manipulation is crazy hard and you might
have to wait too long for a system that
can do all of that but if you can narrow
down the tasks if you can control the
environment um you can specialize your
end of arm tool specialize your grippers
um you can control the lighting the
sensors more uh more directly and this
will allow you to accomplish something
earlier so even though yes it would be
desirable to have a single robot that
could do it all by making this split we
get something in you know two or three
years as opposed to 20 years um and I
think this is the same reason robotics
did so well in manufacturing first
because that's the same task repetitive
over and over and over again so you can
have a highly specialized end of arm
tool that all it does is grip the
windshield or the rear viw mirror and
put it in place we're sort of extending
that a bit um I talk about high clutter
and high contact as the big challenges
we're trying to solve um but it's not
generalized
manipulation so here's what that looks
like um as a work cell design we have a
singulation step that's over here um
this is shown with people I'll show you
some robots that can do this also um and
they're fast enough doing that
singulation just taking the items out
one by one doing a barcode scan they can
feed three robots um so these people are
going you know I don't know a thousand
units per hour the robots are a few
hundred units per
hour uh it does allow you to mature
these Technologies independently so as
soon as we have a good singulation robot
we'll just drop it drop it right in
and this is Amazon one of Amazon
simulation systems it's called Sparrow
so it's a pick and place Bas task uh one
of the cool things about this is all of
those tags all of those um markers allow
us to uh on the Fly determine the pose
of the object in the hand um because we
can calibrate off of those markers and
that enables you to pack much more
densely and so when you pick you don't
know what kind of pose you're going to
get with that item um but you get it in
flight and then you adjust your packing
algorithm so that you can try and fill
up the totes it's going into uh quickly
um for us we don't really need that we
just need the items one by one
singulated out when you use suction cups
to do that kind of picking though really
good at certain things like getting a
credit card off of the bottom of the off
the bottom of the bin um not so good if
you're trying to pick up a book so if
you lift a book you know with a suction
cut by the cover it's going to flop open
uh sort of a redeeming fact about
Humanity in my mind is we still sell so
many books seven 8% something like that
last I checked um so there's still some
readers out there there also a lot of
adult coloring books these days we saw
that go up but um so what do you do with
that there's there's worst cases also
maybe something's in a bag that's loose
and then you pick the bag and the item
stays behind um or you pick a barcode
sticker that's not you know well
attached um in the worst case I actually
saw it was kind of a I'll show examples
of this um it was kind of a wasn't Magic
the Gathering but was this kind of like
card game and the robot picked the lid
of the box and then dropped it and then
one by one picked 100 cards out of the
box and then picked the bottom of the
Box um and so you need a solution for
these kind of things where you don't
have uh uh a good surface for suction um
so these are the failure modes this is
the blooper blooper reel um you know we
you don't want to see your your item
getting handled like that right um and
so I have a team in Berlin Germany and
so we did a project looking at
two-fingered grasp
um which of course is a nice complement
I don't think of it as an alternate I
think of as a complement to suction um
and it handles books it handles these
things one of the big key uh unlocks for
this work was predicting empty space so
yes we need a good 3D representation of
the world but for Pinch grasp um we
actually wanted to have good estimates
of the uded space that you knew you
could put your finger you know
underneath the pile and so we had sort
of multi uh multi view uh cameras and
we're doing like a a sign distance
function representation to try and
predict this um grass poses uh I'll let
it finish we got them all so this was
Cherry pick's video
right and this is going pretty fast as
well so this is over a th units per hour
to give you a sense of the
speed okay so that's the singulation
step and I'll zoom in a little bit more
on the stowing robots for the rest of
the
talk uh one of the things I learned at
Stanford that's been most valuable for
me is iterative design uh we really
embraced that in our workcell um
architecture and in our prototyping
methods so we started with really simple
stuff this is aluminum Extrusion this
thing was candle levered it would wave
back and forth by like you know at like
one or two Hertz um we used blender to
really visualize the workpace um but the
value of doing this kind of prototyping
is that you really understand your
problem a lot better um it also gave the
motion planning and computer vision
teams some early test beds to start
development on um and we knew that we
were going to iterate and so once we got
something that we liked uh we built a
hardened version and this is in a
fulfillment center it's in a warehouse
that's a test warehouse and so it's
processing live orders we get to
exposure to all the variety of items and
Bin conditions and uh edge cases but
there's always kind of a backup plan so
INE inevitably the robot goes down for a
day if you're lucky or a week if if It's
Tricky you know it's not like 5,000
people don't get their birthday presents
in Redwood City um and so we've been
doing this for about a year we've got
100,000 stoves or something like that um
in this test environment and then I'm
very excited we just launched in Spokane
Washington at a live FC uh a prototype
of this um that'll work through the
Christmas season and give us real data
uh and and it's you know it's not a test
environment anymore this is our first
foray into truly the the real world um
we also iterate of course on on the
pieces of the system so the elastic band
separation one of the interesting
failure modes I don't know if any of you
caught this in your head uh when we open
the the bands and pull some of them down
we will trap sometimes an item against
the floor of the bin so imagine like a
t-shirt in a bag you may pin the bag on
the floor of the bin now I try and sweep
it to the side and I'm fighting myself
or I'm ripping that bag open um and so
we moved on I don't know if this video I
think yeah to more of a hook design um
working on both the mechanical design of
that as well as the Motions um we do
have four sensing in the loop on this so
we can PL those motions not just based
on waypoints but also based on um you
know contact and things like that uh we
continued uh this work and I really
wanted to show these videos because they
were made by some of our interns and so
we had a pretty good success rate but
sometimes the top band would slip off uh
we also had this bin lip the fabric lip
along the bottom of that bookshelf it's
fairly stiff and if you're trying to
Stow a tall item you either have to
twist the item to get around that that
bin lip um or otherwise you know deal
with it and so our interns set out to uh
build better mechanical systems and
build better motions and and this is
what they came up with using you know
the UR robots as a test bed and now we
can fuse those into our into our work
cell now that we have data that gives us
confidence in their
performance we also have design
iteration uh in the gripper itself so we
really followed kind of that Ido
brainstorming process we went for volume
we spent you know a good couple of weeks
coming up with every concept we could
think of you know yes and not not no
because uh we filtered those through a
set of criteria and prototyped three or
four of them using you know literally
popsicle sticks and styrofoam and things
this was right Peak pandemic and so we
were doing this sometimes in our home
with you know cereal boxes in the pantry
um and once we got something we like we
matured it and so we picked this style
these two plates and we call it a panini
gripper um I hope that is obvious why uh
we liked that because you have sixed off
pose control of the item so if you have
a two-finger gripper and you've got a
t-shirt it's going to be flopping around
you you're not able to control that
precisely as you try and stow it um the
other reason we really liked it is you
have a known engineering surface that
you're making contact with the world
which is the back of the paddle so
rather than trying to push you know with
a book on one stow and then push with a
t-shirt on the next stow and then push
with a teddy bear and then a bowling
ball uh we have this at least one side
of the contact is well modeled well
understood and that involved into a
special bin manipulator this piece of
sheet metal and in V1 that was kind of a
fruit ninja like it would it would
rotate and chop down um and then it
became more of like a Wolverine style
where it would extend out from inside
the hand um the latest thing we've done
here is move the force torque sensor
from the wrist um out to that paddle so
that we don't have all the inertia and
and losses of this you know end of arm
tool that's a couple of kilograms and
that's actually really improved our
control
bandwidth so here's what that looks like
you know next steps of course also are
some design for manufacturing some some
cost engineering things like that um one
of the other uh things I'm proud of with
this work is on the electrical side so
Amazon and most you know Warehouse
robotics industrial robotics folks are
using you know sort of system
integration techniques and so you have a
big electrical cabinet with you know
Servo drives that cost you know 500% of
what you think they should cost if
you've taken 218 um and you run all
these cables that are way bigger and
stiffer than you might need them to be
uh and so with four Servo Motors and
force torque sensors and limit switches
I think we were up to 50 15 or 16 cables
in this enormous you know fire hose like
dress pack um and as you're trying to do
compliant control and you've got a 10 PB
cable flopping around I can tell you
that generated a lot of noise um that
was was affecting our ability to
understand what was happening between
the gripper and the and the the items so
we built our own embedded um board with
some of those motor drivers we're using
ethercat as a protocol um so found some
ethercat Servo drivers and now we have
single connector right we're down to
five conductors I think from 64 and you
know 15
cables so this is the other thing
iteration gets
you if I shift kind of to the robotic
science side of the problem um there's
two primary uh um areas I like to talk
about one is compliant control so adding
that force and torque in the loop signal
you know high bandwidth couple hundred
Hertz uh in that control Loop and then
the second is the decision-making so we
definitely need a good 3D representation
of the scene um so the computer vision
piece is foundational but that's not
enough so it's not a Peg and hole
problem um because the hole is not
always there we have to create the hole
and so you have to reason over that 3D
representation of the scene and predict
where you might be able to make space if
you were to do some of these motions so
um you have to create the hole and then
your peg is shaped like an Amazon item
which again is Teddy Bear and then
bowling ball and then USB stick so I'll
talk about each of these um we have
other science robotic science that that
we leverage so a lot of free space
motion planning but here we're not
really trying to invent we're trying to
capture what's what's already
state-of-the-art and so we do um KO uh
formulations for our free space motion
planning which is from Mark tant over in
tu Berlin um we've also done some of the
techniques that Russ uh tedrick out at
MIT has has put forward um we are also
running uh always kind of a recovery
plan um so that when we don't make
enough room and we think we can sweep
you know 10 cm but we were wrong and we
only get six and the item in our hand is
too big we want to have an immediate way
to recycle that item so at Amazon you
know those seconds count uh and so
having to wait there to recalculate you
know your your recovery trajectory is
costs a lot of
money when we think about the the first
science challenge where I would say
we're doing some of this advention um
that force and torque in the loop
control we've experimented with
impedance um style controllers with
torque sensing at each joint torque
control at each joint in the robot arm
um and we've also played around with
admittance controllers where we are only
using the force torque sensing at the
wrist or even now further out at the
blade and we landed on the admittance
side of this you know classic debate um
because the contact is always occurring
through that blade it's never the case
in our application where the elbow of
the robot is getting um into contact UM
nor are we able to generate kind of a
good model so our impedance controllers
would fail because we would pick up an
item that would have sort of unknown or
uh or not well-modeled uh Mass
properties and then we we weren't able
to kind of keep a good model of the
robot um updated so I think in in the
long run it's maybe more ideal but we
found the admittance control was really
practical and and viable for our
application another simplification that
made this attractable problem was not
trying to imagine any motion Under the
Sun we have canonical motion Primitives
and so it uh uh collapses to a problem
of picking which primitive and which
initial conditions to use use as opposed
to trying to come up with a new strategy
on every bin um and so we have these
four Primitives slot wedge uh really is
the Peg and hole problem there's empty
space or it's an empty bin just go Chuck
an item into that bin stacking is sort
of similar you have an empty space but
we are reasoning about the stability of
that pile um using surface normals um uh
to decide whether or not it's going to
stay there or fall out later bin sweeps
are probably the most common here you
might have a stack of library books that
has fallen over or a bunch of discret
items with spaces in between we insert
that sheet metal blade and then push
everything to the side to consolidate
the the available space even compressing
sometimes those items that are t-shirts
or or other things that that are not
harmed by being squeezed probably the
most fun is flip up so here's where a
book has fallen over flat in the bin you
don't want to create a pile um that
actually makes it harder for the people
that have to pick the items out if
you're trying to get the book off the
bottom of the pile it's way worse than
getting the book out of the middle of
the the library shelf um and so we put
that blade underneath the item and then
rotate it up to the side and there are
sort of um variants of these it's more
of a spectrum than really four discret
points but um I'll show you
videos so here's slot wedge again this
is the easiest empty bin or empty space
take the item and put it in in fact now
we make a calculation about whether we
even need to extend that sheet metal
blade it's an empty bin just you know
aim for the middle and and go as fast as
you
can for stacking um we have methods
where we actually use that blade to push
down the elastic bands so that the pile
won't fall out or we have a lower
probability of the item that we're
putting in the bin to fall out um H but
we're essentially inserting things on
top what I'm not showing is some of the
surface normal calculations that that
we've done recently recently um this is
kind of an ugly pile we we generally
would not want to Stack an entire bin
we'd want to put one item on top um only
when it's very dense this is actually a
knob that they turn on and off in
operations so uh during the nine months
of the year before now um they will ban
stacking they'll tell all the people
like don't stack any items um and when
we get ready for the holiday Rush
they're like any way possible get those
bins as full as you can
so from a robotic perspective we can
also turn that on and off depending on
conditions okay so here are bin
[Music]
sweeps um and this is sort of
interesting because there's more steps
in the process so we're indexing you
know we touch the the item there to
index off of before moving to the wall
of the bookshelf to do the full blade
insertion um and that takes out some of
the error you know your perception
system might have one or two centim of
stacked up error and so that's too much
to have a high reliability um blade
insertion in these dense bins and so
we'll do the same thing a human does
when they're picking up a coin off of a
table rather than trying to go precisely
to the spot in space where you can grasp
that coin you go to a reference make
contact and then slide along that
contact UM until you can accomplish the
task um you'll see different strategies
here sometimes we're inserting the blade
above the items and kind of sweeping
down sometimes we're seeking out that
wall that's uh the fabric wall and
sometimes we are uh just going into
empty space uh where we have confidence
that there's not going to be a collision
of the
blade you can see this is with the old
gripper if you look closely there's this
nasty bundle of cables that are on the
back
and one of the other interesting things
I think from a science perspective that
we're doing is when we Stow to the same
bin multiple times we use memory so we
know how much space we were able to
create when we did the sweep um and so
you can use that rather than your
perception output because you have now a
ground truth measurement you can use
that to update the bin item match as
well as the um uh the kinds of uh motion
Primitives that you might use
so here's flip up
um we're also you know again trying to
make these fast and so that's that's a
challenge um that's why you want that
really clean Force TK signal because you
don't want to sit there and filter it um
for a long
time yeah okay so I'm going to switch
over to the other science problem now
which is the
decision-making um
and so the seed of that is the computer
vision um here we also took an iterative
approach so it's the same principles
whether you're in Hardware or software
um we started with something simple
which is an occupancy map uh basically
it's a yellow not yellow model right
when the bookshelf is all yellow that's
what it's learning um we also had a a
elastic band segmentation mask so we
know where to put in that hook to to
lift the um elastic bands out of the way
we evolved this pretty quickly um and so
the logical next step of course is is
segmentation and um we've actually got
you know instance segmentation we're
actually labeling the items now
sometimes we're able to tell which item
it is based on Dimensions or or color uh
RGB embeddings that kind of thing um and
so we will uh we will use that to
determine whether we can compress the
stack or not for instance um we would
really love to have some depth
information that would help you um we
are confounded by those elastic bands so
the traditional techniques you oh just
use a lar you know projected light you
know pattern these don't work well at
all because you get all these false
returns from the elastic bands and so
what our team is doing instead is trying
to infer depth from monocular images so
the problem is fairly structured um we
can collect ground Truth uh data with
those kind of Lars and and other sensors
active sensors when the bands are
removed um and then compare them to the
2D images we have and because of the
structure of the problem we can actually
get a fairly good um inferred depth
model can also use simulation so that's
what's shown here that gives you ground
truth really easily lets you build up a
backbone of your model and then you know
you augment it with some real data from
the field
um the other thing we do um to deal with
those elastic bands we have something
called Blind in painting so some of your
cell phones have this if you have you
know someone who's photobombed you uh
you can kind of Magic Eraser them out uh
same techniques here to uh hallucinate
the pixels behind the elastic bands and
if we do this as a pre-processing step
before the segmentation uh we do get
better results um again works pretty
well because our domain is fairly well
defined so this is again that difference
between a general you know works
everywhere in the wild problem and you
know how to structure your system so
automation will have a good chance
uh yaw and perspective this was the one
that surprised me I sort of thought we
would be able to geometrically handle
this um but it turns out it's a lot
harder than we initially thought um it's
challenging because both the floor of
the bin and this and the wall of the bin
are that same yellow fabric so your uh
you know your camera has a hard time
determining um especially when that
floor might have a curvature because
it's fabric um the other problem here is
the item might be pushed all the way
back against the back of the bin or may
be way up at the front um and if you
have a box it could be sitting perfectly
square or it could be yaw and so in your
2D image you may have some bin that
looks like it's completely full your
manifest says you know it should be a
quarter full and it's because that item
is rotated in the bin um and so we've
done a lot of work to try and correct
for that prospective error um and you
know sort of do orthographic
reprojection to to accommodate the angle
that you're looking out at the the edges
of the um of the outer bins so this is
still work in progress um but for the
computer vision folks in the room if you
have ideas you know this is my
solicitation um another Improvement we
made was labeling every pixel pixel in
the scene um and some of this is useful
like that bin lip understanding where
that bin lip is you can change your your
strategy also we have these metal bars
that are the frame of the Pod and
obviously you get a different response
if you sweep your um piece of uh your
bin manipulator into the metal bar than
you do if you are pushing a T-shirt and
so knowing where those are also gives us
better performance um and and so this
was a step up uh and now we've moved on
to infer depth from stereo which I know
sounds a little weird you generally
think you're going to do dent stereo
geometrically but we're actually taking
the stereo as inputs and then training a
model um again using that ground truth
depth sensing um because of the elastic
bands so when we try to make a decision
about which of the 30 or 40 items that
are available to us should go into which
of the 25 or 30 bins are on the
bookshelf in front of us um we currently
have you know sort of a decision tree
that some of those leaves have a little
bit of ml in them um but it's in at the
highest level it's kind of a one- siiz
fits-all so we're not adjusting in that
model for when we have a one pound item
versus a 1 oun item versus a 5 pound
item we're not adjusting it for when the
bin is super full versus pretty empty um
and so we've uh engaged in some work
with a professor from University of
Washington Lilian Ratliff who's on
sabatical with us to try and model risk
so that we can have uh more tailored
motions depending on the bin State and
depending on the um the item that we're
stowing um the other thing that we like
to do as a good example of the value of
this work is you might want to Stow the
first six items that you can fit into
the bin face um using a fairly
conservative set of rules but when
you're ready to kick out that pod when
you say I can't Stow anymore that's the
time when you should take risk right
that's the time when you might want to
say well I have 88% confidence or 92%
confidence in this Stow now you can do a
assessment of the time penalty it's
going to cost if you fail versus the
extra
you know the value you get from that um
and so lilian's working on this uh it's
super exciting so this is sort of my my
penultimate slide um what I hope you
take away from The Talk today um besides
that oh cool like that's a fun robotics
application I hope you do take that away
it's super fun um way more fun than I
thought it was going to be actually when
I made that that leap from the volcano
robots into into warehouse robots but um
the other thing I hope you leave with is
an understanding of some of the problems
that we face um in industrial robotics
uh as we try and take research results
from the lab and apply them um in a
business setting and so I tried to list
some of the problems we face and I hope
maybe some of you can see how your
research here fits into some of these
domains um and might provide answers to
to the problems we have now and with the
next uh applications um of course we
also have job opportunities for um
bright Stanford graduates um and folks
looking for
internships uh so there is a jobs
website if you look for Amazon robotics
there's a bunch of of posts there i'
also just encourage you to connect with
me on LinkedIn um and I can direct you
to to whichever is the appropriate place
for you I have saved time for questions
and so I'm excited to hear what you
think
hi uh great talk it seemed like a lot of
the it seemed like a lot of the problems
that you were dealing with are also
related to the fans in front of the
things right so I know this is a huge
scale operation and those bins are maybe
throughout the world but was there ever
the option to like
question whether you could change the
bins themselves to make your hold
robotics problem easier and give a
bigger P at the end yeah which is is the
philosophy I was kind of espousing right
like um yeah we did consider that uh and
you're right the scale of this is
enormous so in the world I think there's
around five million of those bookshelves
so not only is it the cost but it's also
the like the logistics and the labor to
change them all um in Amazon we talk
about green fields and brown Fields I
think that's actually pretty common
terminology uh out out in the you know
warehousing world and so it's much
easier if you're talking about a new
building a green field building um to
consider other architectures my team has
been pretty focused and I try to I try
to drive them to like stay on this
target of surgical retrofits so we
already have 100 buildings right or 150
buildings um they exist try and live in
the world that already exists um there's
a different project at Amazon you can
you can look it up um where they're
looking at contain aized storage so
you'll see a lot of systems out there uh
often referred to as asrs automated
storage and retrieval systems basically
have tubs that are moving around um and
so rather than having vertical shelves
which you know is is sort of a challenge
for robotics you have a a a bin so that
you gravity is working in your favor um
so there's a project at Amazon that's
already pushing on that domain um and so
we we really are trying not to change
the world that exists the other thing is
like in the big amazon ecosystem that I
showed you in that initial video it
is you know 20 processes in the building
and so when you start changing things
those can have unintended consequences
upstream and
downstream and so for instance our
quality control is trained on the thing
that exists and so if you change it
you're changing their their domain as
well um but yeah it was a hard
discussion that we had yeah yeah thank
you so much for the talk so you talked
about the computer vision problem where
you were having issues estimating the
depth so what you were doing basically
was capturing stereo images getting the
disparity image and then calculating the
depth right so why don't we use any
Dynamic volume rendering technique like
radian speeds so basically for each and
every compartment there is a simple
multile perceptron which is uh really
really easy to compress and it is
computationally very inexpensive so
every time something gets stored uh into
that shelf the corresponding model will
get updated and it is very easy to
estimate depth information out of neural
gruse so why don't you think this is
a yeah uh it's a good question good line
of thinking um so thank you for that uh
we have what we call a course update and
a fine update in the stack and so when
the Pod shows up initially we're Imaging
everything right and we haven't lifted
the elastic bands yet and so the elastic
bands are really what kind of of degrade
the performance of that uh like
disparity matching technique uh and
that's why we use the inferred depth
it's in that course update we do capture
images whenever we lift up the elastic
bands and that gives you this better you
know uh uh View and so we do what we
call a fine update and that uses some
other techniques um to try and refine
this data the bin
um so I don't think that's a perfect
answer to your question like you could
still ask well why don't we used that
strategy in the beginning and U all I
can tell you is like we are trying these
things and and um so far this is this is
the best performance that we've been
able to get yeah my question is like
when you're putting things in versus put
putting things out why are you like
making specific Hardware solutions for
one and the other cuz if you like if you
made the hardware the same like you know
I know it's difficult I'm assuming to
like make sure that it's going to be the
same but if you made a general and then
you like basically sent the problem to
the cord effectively would that be
easier um easier for the hardware
Engineers uh yeah so we looked at this
too of course and we did a big analysis
that say so uh Amazon will actually Flex
some of the stations back and forth
between pick and Stow depending October
we're doing a lot of stowing you know
Black Friday you know December we're
doing a lot of picking right so the
fullness of the bins will ramp up and
then as people start doing their holiday
shopping it'll be a steady decline um
it it just turned out to be too
difficult from the manipulation task so
for stowing you know we like to have
that pose control of the item for
picking that's not important you know if
the item dangles uh it's okay um for
stowing uh you know we're feeding that
item in with the conveyor belts it'd be
pretty difficult to get the item
essentially started so we'd need some
kind of suction system or some kind of
uh gripper to get to get that started um
we are trying to share as much of the
hardware as we can and so the 7th e
access Gantry the band separation some
of the software interfaces as well to
like accept the pods and and send them
out and log into the stations all of
that stuff is shared um but we are
strategic about you know when it's
easier and when it's it's it's sort of
harder and kind of fell into that
General manipulation category it was
just it was kind of too hard for us to
make it the same
yeah uh yeah um in the rare case of
objects falling out of the Pod say the
gripper drops that R it's not that rare
okay say the gripper drops the object or
when you when you move the elastic band
because of the orientation of the object
falls off yeah the does the system know
and second what happens yeah
um so sometimes the system knows so we
do have an overhead camera and we have
an amnesty detection model and we have
an overhang model which is like an
amnesty risk model um and so if we
detect the item uh and we can tell which
item it was then we'll autonomously heal
the system right and we'll just make
sure that the inventory record is is
clean and then once a day a person will
come come around and pick up the 10
items that are on the floor and and put
them back if they're not damaged um
there are cases though where you don't
know or you don't know which item it is
um and this happens with people as well
and so there's already an established
Quality Control process in place that um
you know it'll it's called a pick short
you know basically it'll come to a
station and say pick the iPad and you're
look in you're like there's no iPad in
this bin um and then it knows that
there's a defect and and maybe somebody
found an iPad out on the floor and
they're like oh these two go together
right um so there's a bunch of systems
like that to deal with the edge cases I
say it's not that rare because again you
know something like 10 million picks per
day right so we get a lot of
it yeah other
questions shirt do you have trouble with
people picking yellow or reflective
items um we don't have trouble with
people picking those items we do have
trouble you know of course our
segmentation model is not perfect um so
yellow items are one flavor of error
reflective items or dark items also you
know classically cause challenges
sometimes um yeah so we have errors in
our segmentation masks
um that are that are based on that on
the pick side um the errors we have are
when you have items that look very
similar to one another or uh we also
have models that are trying to tell if
items are including other items so you
don't try and pick an item that's behind
one and then pull out pull out the item
that's blocking it um so there is a
bunch of those kinds of cases that do
exist yes and that's kind of the long
tail of going from proof of concept to
product yeah you mentioned that control
reques model of what you're picking have
you looked at online system
identification or learning yes uh yes we
have uh and so we did do some of that
and then uh tried to update our models
and I would say mixed results
um I I think
that you know I think we you could make
that technique work
and it was just that the admittance
control felt like an easier path or or
the data told us it was an easier path
at the time that we were doing that
exploration um and so yeah we were
putting chirp of signals and trying to
build up that model and um we're making
progress right that's the right way to
attack that problem but I think it got
cut short a little bit it's not a dead
end it was just a harder path yeah go
ahead did you
investigate for this since academ
so yeah we have some of our interns as
it turns out investigate some of those
techniques for us I I like to use um our
interns to sort of get one step ahead of
the team and like triage is this is
there juice in this orange or is it dry
um
and
uh yeah with the reliability we were
trying to get to like you know RL was
not was not sufficiently performant um
at that time this was last like 18
months ago summer that we really
investigated it
um
yeah going
once have questions yeah maybe we'll
break here again for
[Applause]
our